مرحبا بكم لا يكاد يمر اسبوع دون ان تشير
مصادر يمنيه الى ممارسات جديده من
الامارات ومن تدعمهم بالمال والسلاح في
محافظات اليمن الجنوبيه تثير حفيظه
اليمنيين في هذه المحافظه او تلك وتشبه
تلك الاعمال احيانا بالاحتلال وتعتبر في
احيان اخرى تعتبرها مسا بسياده الشرعيه
اليمنيه ومصالح البلاد جديد هذه الاعمال
ما حملته رساله من محافظ سقطره الى الرئيس
عبد ربو منصور هادي ي شكو فيها دور المجلس
الانتقالي الجنوبي المدعوم من الامارات
ومسلحين ومرتزقه يقول ان ابو ظبي جاءت بهم
الى
المحافظه ماذا الامارات فاعله اكثر في
وبجز سقطره اليمنيه امام ما يجري من
انتهاكات بالارض والبشر لا يجد محافظ
الجزيره رمزي محروس سوى مخاطبه الرئيس عبد
الربو منصور هادي استعرض في رساله الشكوى
قائمه طويله من التجاوزات التي تكبل يد
الشرعيه وتطلق يد مسلحي ابو ظبي القدامى
والجدد في المنطقه ورد فيها ان الاداره
الذاتيه المعلنه من قبل المجلس الانتقالي
الجنوبي المدعوم من الامارات قائمه حتى
اللحظه ومعها يستمر نهب ثروات سقطره كما
ابلغ الرئيس هادي ان تفويض الحكومه
الانتقالي بصلاحيه ماليه اضعف موقف
الشرعيه تواصل السلطات المنبثقه عن المجلس
الانتقالي والتي انقلبت على الشرعيه في
اكثر من محافظه خاليه من الحوثيين منع
المنافذ من مزاوله عملها حديث ايضا عن
انشاء مواقع عسكريه جديده في شرق سقطره
وغربها وفي الساحل الشمالي وحرم المطار
واخطر ما ورد في الرساله هو تجنيد ابو ظبي
مئات المسلحين او المرتزقه لمحاربه ابناء
الجزيره المطالبين بعوده مؤسسات الدوله
والرافضين لما يسمونه الاحتلال الاماراتي
جاء خطاب محروس بعد تصريحات وزير الثروه
السمكيه فهد كفايا في الاونه الاخيره قال
حينها ان ابو ظبي ادخلت شخصيات اجنبيه
للارخص رسميه ودون ختم لجوازات واستقدمت
معدات اتصال متقدمه حسب الوزير وافرغ مسلح
الانتقال حموله سفينه اماراتيه في احد
موانئ الجزيره
اكد اكثر من مصدر يمني من داخل الشرعيه
وخارجها تعزيز الوجود العسكري لابو ظبي في
سقطره خلال شهر سبتمبر الجاري وبشكل لافت
جدا استنادا لتلك المصادر فقد ركزت
الامارات على ارسال دفعات جديده من جنودها
ومن المرتزقه الاجانب مع الاستغناء
التدريجي عن مسلحي المجلس الانتقالي الذين
طلب من بعضهم العوده الى عدن وحضرموت اله
الاعلاميه القائمه بين الشرعيه والانتقالي
هل تستغلها الامارات لتنفيذ اجندتها دون
ازعاج التاخر في تشكيل الحكومه اليمنيه
الجديده والمنتظره منذ فتره لا يعجل بعوده
الامور الى سابق عهدها لا في سقطره ولا
المهره ولا عدن ماذا بقي من اتفاق الرياض
بنسختيه الميتتين على الارض اعتبرت منظمه
اف الدوليه لحقوق الانسان ومقرها بروكسل
التحركات الاخيره في اليمن وخاصه سقطره
جريمه عدوان متكامله الاركان وصفى بيان
المنظمه ما يجري بالانتهاك الفادح للسياده
اليمنيه العبث بسقط واهلها وثرواتها
وسحرها الطبيعي الى
متى لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا عبر
الانترنت عادل الحسني القيادي في المقاومه
الجنوبيه اليمنيه ومعنا من بيروت اسعد
بشاره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما
اسعد بشاره سنبدا معك كيف قرات رساله
محافظ سقطره رمزي محروس لناحيه ما ورد
فيها من شكاوه عن ممارسات يقوم بها المجلس
الانتقالي المدعوم اماراتيا في
سقطره كل هذه الشكاوى هي تعبير عن امر
واقع لم يحسن بعد لان الاتفاق الرياض او
الاتفاق على اي يعني تشكيل سلطه والاندماج
مع الشرعيه بين المجلس الانتقالي وال يعني
الشرعيه هذه لم يحصل بعد اذا يبقى القديم
على قدمه بانتظار اتمام هذا الاتفاق وما
دام هذا الاتفاق لم يتم بعد فان سقطره
معروف انها باتت تحت سيطره الانتقالي منذ
المعركه الشهيره اسوه لكن القديم ليس على
قدمه سيد اسعد وفق هذه الرساله ووفق ما
ورد فيها يتحدث عن تمدد للق قواعد للقواعد
التابعه للانتقالي عن ادخال مقاتلين وصفهم
بالمرتزقه عن ادخال وفود اجنبيه معدات
اتصال عن نهب معسكرات اذا الوضع يتطور ما
هو التفسير
لذلك لا في في تناقض ببعض بالمعلومات انه
من جهه يتحدث عن تتحدث عن تعزيز دور
الانتقالي للسيطره اكثر على سقطره بعد ان
باتت تح سيطرته ومن جهه عن استقدام
تعزيزات اجنبيه او يعني مرتزقه اجانب
لاقصاء دور الانتقالي كيف يكون هذا لا هو
لا يتحدث عن مقاتلين اجانب ويتحدث عن
مقاتلين من مناطق اخرى من مناطق اخرى داخل
اليمن داخل اليمن ت هؤلاء يمنيون هؤلاء
يمنيون نعم ولكنهم ياتون من خارج المحافظه
لدعم واسناد قوات المجلس
الانتقالي لا باس انا اتحدث عن استمرار
القديم على قدمه يعني كل الترسيم الذي حصل
بعد المشكله في عدن وبعد يعني المشكله بين
الشرعيه والمجلس الانتقالي الجنوبي لم تحل
بعد لم تحل بعد هناك مش اشكال سياسي كبير
ناتج عن عدم القدره على ان يكون الجميع في
ضمن شرعيه واحده شرعيه الرئيس هذه وهناك
اشكال كبير على على الارض على يعني موضوع
المحافظات هناك اشكال على موضوع تشكيل
الحكومه والوزارات السياديه والوزارات
الحساسه الامنيه وغير الامنيه هناك اشكال
على تعيين المحافظين يعني كل هذه
الاشكاليات لم تحل بعد ولم يظهر بعد طيب
ولكن يعني وانت تتحدث عن ان القديم عن ان
القديم باق على قدمه بانتظار حل اي ما دام
الاتفاق لم يحصل نعم بانتظار حل الاشكال
كيف تفسر اذا الشكوى الوارده ايضا في هذه
الرساله من ان ا يعني موضوع الاداره
الذاتيه
باق كما هو مع العلم ان احد الشروط للعوده
والتفاوض من اجل الوصول الى اتفاق الرياض
اثنين كان الرجوع عن الاداره الذاتيه من
جانب المجلس
الانتقالي صحيح وهذا موقف لا رجوع عنه متى
حصل الاتفاق وانا كل ما اقوله هو ان
الاتفاق لم يحصل بعد وبالتالي هناك
مترتبات على الشرعيه اليمنيه ايضا لم يتم
الايفاء بها هناك صراع على الوزارات صرام
على تقاسم السلطه هناك صراع يمتد في كل
بكل تفاصيله من الالف الى الياء ما دام
هذا الاتفاق لم يحصل انا لا اعتقد ان هناك
ترسيخ للاداره الذاتيه من قبل المجس
الجنوبي الان هناك يعني ستاتيكو معين في
جنوب اليمن ينتظر حصول الاتفاق او عدم
حصول الاتفاق اذا لم يحصل هذا الاتفاق
بالطبيعي بالطبع ستتعزز الاتجاه السلبي
الى الاداره الذاتيه وستكون الشرعيه
اليمنيه امام استحقاقات اخرى مختلفه يكون
هناك مواجهه ولكن الجميع ينتظر الان هل
سيحصل هذا الاختراق هل ان مفاوض مستمره في
الرياض دع ناخذ هذه النقاط التي اثرت سيد
اسعد الى ضيفنا السيد عادل الحسني سيد
عادل اذا ما يجري في
سقطره هو بقاء القديم على قدمه لانه لم
يحدث بعد الاختراق المتوقع في الاتفاق بين
الاطراف في الجنوب اليمني هذا ما يقوله
ضيفنا اسعد بشاره ما
رايك بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير
عليك وعلى الاستاذ اسعد والساده المتابعين
في البدايه دعيني ان اترحم على سمو الشيخ
الصباحي اهل حامد جبر الصباح امير دوله
الكويت الذي وافته المنيه في هذه الليله
والشعب اليمني حقيقه يكن لدوله الكويت كل
الحب والاحترام ل بصماتها الطيبه
والانسانيه في بلدنا اليمن بالنسبه لما
الحديث الاستاذ اسعد يعني حقيقه هو خلاف
الواقع وما يجري في سقطره يعني من استمرار
لسلسله من الانتهاكات وبناء القواعد
العسكريه ودخول الاجانب
وبناء المعسكرات واستقلاب المسلحين وخروج
السلطه
الشرعيه اخيرا تفويض من قبل معين عبد
الملك الذي فرضته السعوديه والامارات على
الرئيس هادي كرئيس للحكومه لمجلس
الانتقالي في في في سقطره كل هذا ياتي في
سياق يعني مكتمل لبسط النفوذ الاماراتي
على هذا الارخبيل التي يعني لا تخفي
الامارات اطماعها عنه وقد حدثنا ضباط
اماراتيون من اول يوم عنده نزلوا الى الى
الى اليمن ان لهم يعني اجنده ولهم اطماع
لكن على اساس انهم سيدخل في اتفاقيات مع
الحكومه لكن عندما راوا الرئيس يعني لم
يسمح لهم في توقيعات معينه شقوا طريقهم
وسلبوا هذه المليشيات
المرح هذا كان سائدا في المرحله التي سيطر
فيها المجلس الانتقالي على سقطره الان هل
الوضع
يتبدل لا لم يتبدل الوضع بل ازداد سوءا
الوضع في في سقطره يعني ومن خلال رساله
الاخ المحافظ ان الخبيل يبتعد يوما بعد
يوم عن السياده الوطنيه عن عن الجمهوريه
عن عن زياده عن الكرامه يعني قد يذهب
ادراج الرياح يعني كلام خطير جدا ان تبنى
قواعد عسكريه وان يستجلب يعني اجانب الى
هذه الارخبيل ما الذي يراد في هذا
الارخبيل من هذا القواعد التي ستبنى ما هي
البرامج ما هي الاجنده يعني كلها علامات
استفهام كبيره وخطيره خاصه ان هذا
الارخبيل وهذه الجزيره تقع في موقع حساس
واستراتيجي يطل على القرن الافريقي على
المحيط الهندي على باب المندب على السفون
الدوليه فلا شك ما هي باعتقادك هذه
الاجنده التي تتساءل عنها سيد
عادل والله نحن تكلمنا مبكرا وقلنا ذلك
لكن نحن يسموننا خصوم الامارات ويقولون
اننا ندعي لكن اليوم يتكلم الجهات الرسميه
يتكلم المحافظ يتكلم وزير الثروه السمكيه
اليوم دخلت سفن يعني بتصريح المحافظ
بتصريح وزير الثروه السمكيه سفن محمله
بادوات ومعدات رفضت التفتيش حتى نائب رئيس
الوزراء الخنبشي واوصل رساله الى رمزي
محروس انهم وجهوا بعدم دخول السفينه لكن
الامارات ادخلت هذه السفينه اليوم معدات
وبنا قواعد في شرق سقط طيب لماذا السؤال
هو لماذا نحن نحن علمنا بما حدث ولكن
لماذا ما هي الاهداف البعيده
باعتقادك الاهداف واضحه يعني قلت لك اختي
الكريمه الامارات واسرائيل عندهم قواعد في
جزيره عصب في اريتيريا واليوم ينشؤون جو
قواعد عسكريه في البحار اليمنيه سواء كان
في عصب في عفوا في ميدي او في سقطره او في
ميون كل هذه الجزر مهمه جدا و وهي تخرج عن
سيطره الحكومه اليمنيه يوما بعد يوم بعد
اخراج السلطه الشرعيه من سقطره اتضحت
الامور وانكشفت الحقائق ان القوم لهم
برنامج واضح وسيطره واحتلال لكن لكن سيد
عادل يعني لو اطلت معك ولكن اريد ان الف
نظرك الى امر ورد في رساله رمزي محروس
المحافظ هو ويشكو تفويض الحكومه صلاحيات
ماليه للانتقالي يعني الا عندما يشكو
تفويض الحكومه الا يتهم هنا الحكومه بانها
تغطي ما
يحدث المعلومات التي لدي ان وزير الماليه
فوض بعض الموظفين هناك لمده ثلاث اشهر
لتسيير قضيه المرتبات واحتياجات الناس في
ظل غياب السلطه الشرعيه هنا لكن الذي يضع
علامات استف ها وتعجب
و وشيء يعني يعني خطير وهو تفويض رئيس
الوزراء معين عبد الملك بكامل الصلاحيه
لهؤلاء الذين انقلبوا على الدوله واخذوا
مؤسسات الدوله والويه عسكريه وسيطروا على
السلاح وانزلوا علم الدوله واستبدلوه بعلم
الانفصال وعلم الامارات كيف يتم تفض هؤلاء
وما هي العوائد الماليه واين تذهب هناك
يعني شكوك وهناك تسريبات خطيره ان معين
عبد الملك ومعه عصابات وميليشيات شرك في
هذه الاموال التي لا لا ندري اين تذهب طيب
اسعد بشاره ربما استمعت الى ما قاله السيد
عادل الحسني عن ربما مخطط لانشاء قواعد في
عدد من الجزر الجزر منها سقطره قواعد
عسكريه اماراتيه اسرائيليه هذا ايضا امر
اثير لدى موقع انتلجنس اون
لاين قبل فتره كيف تنظر السعوديه الى لكل
ذلك يعني بابتسامه ساخره لان هذا الموضوع
لا يمكن وضعه على الطاوله والنقاش فيه
كموضوع
جدي يعني قواعد اسرائيليه في اليمن وهل ان
الشعب اليمني يعني يقبل بهذا بهذا الموضوع
باعتقادي ان مهمه التحك متف تما شو لدى
اليمنيين في سقطره من انه يتم تجاوز كل
سياده الط اليمني في الممارسات التي تحصل
هناك انا على فرض س
اصدق الفوب
الفوبيا الموضوعه حول الامارات بالنسبه
لمطامع معينه في اليمن على فرض هذا
الموضوع هل تستطيع الامارات بقدراتها ان
تبقى في اليمن يوما واحدا بدون موافقه
الشعب اليمني او بدون وجود ارضيه مهيئه
لهذا الموضوع بالطبع لا هل ان الخطه هي
خطه التحالف هي التمركز في اليمن بالطبع
لا خطه التحالف هي الانسحاب من اليمن بعد
يعني الدفاع عن اليمن بوجه المطامع
الايرانيه حصرا وبعد هذه ال تحقيق هذا
الهدف اذا تحقق هذا الهدف لن يبقوا يوما
واحدا لان لا مطمع بالوجود في اليمن لا
مطمع استراتيجي ولا مطمع من حيث الثروات
ولا اي مطمع اخر بالعكس ان الاستمرار في
التواجد العسكري في اليمن هو عبء على هذا
التحالف وتعتقد ان السعوديه السعوديه يعني
يعني هذا هو موقفها هي تعتبر انه لا توجد
اي مطامع للامارات في اليمن تتجاوز الدور
المرسوم لهذا
التحالف حتما كان هناك تنسيق دائم مع
الامارات رغم الاماراتي السعودي لان هذه
المهمه هي مهمه واحده اهدافها واحده على
الرغم من بعض وجود بعض التميز زد في
التعاطي مع الاطراف اليمنيين خاصه في جنوب
اليمن ولكن في المحصله مهمه التحالف ليست
محصوره فقط باليمن يعني السعوديه
والامارات هناك دول اخرى عربيه مشاركه في
هذا التحالف بطريقه او باخرى الهدف
المركزي واضح ولا غبار عليه اما محاوله
بعض الاطراف اليمنيين اثاره الغبار حول
مطاعم مطامع ومطامع يعني بال انا اختم
واقول هنا اختم واقول هنا يعني دوله
امارات العربيه المتحده ان هذه الفوبيا من
الامارات ليست مكانها
ليست وصلت الفكره سيد اسعد عادل الحسني
اذا الامارات لا مطامع لديها وهي لا
تستطيع اصلا البقاء في اليمن من دون
موافقه اليمنيين ما
رايك والله لو الاستاذ اسعد يكلف نفسه
ويتابع المغردين الاماراتيين ويتابع وسائل
الاعلام الاماراتيه كيف يتحدثون عن سقط
وكانها جزيره اماراتيه ويتهكم بمحافظ
سقطره وانهم اخرجوا المحافظ يعني هل
يريدون الاستاذ اسعد ان نغطي اعيننا وان
ننسى جزيرتنا يا اخي هذه جزيرتنا هذه
ارضنا نحن نتحدث لا نتحدث عن دبي ولا عن
عجمان ولا عن ابو ظبي نحن نتحدث عن جزيره
في بلادنا اليوم الذي يحكم هذه الجزيره هو
خلفان المزروعي وكل ابناء الجزيره يتحدثون
عن ذلك اذا كان المحافظ يتحدث عن ذلك وشيخ
مشايخ سوطرا يتحدث عن ذلك والسلطه المحليه
تتحدث عن ذلك وقيادات الامن تتحدث عن ذلك
والمواطنين يتحدثوا عن عن دلك نكذب هؤلاء
كلهم يا استاذ اسعد و نصدقك من لبنان هذا
شيء لا لا هذا شي غير منير سيد ع امام هذا
الواقع الذي تقول انه يتمدد ويتطور ما
تفسيرك لصمت الرئاسه
اليمنيه والله الرئاسه في في في في في
القرف المغلقه تقول شيء والاعلام يعني
للاسف الشديد تقول شيء الرئيس عندما يجتمع
بالكثير من الوزراء وكثير من القيادات
يقولها بمل الفم انه يعني يساوم على سقطره
وانه لن يفرد في سقطره وانه رفض التوقيع
عن سقطره وان اليوم يتم فرض معين عبد
الملك عليه وان هناك ضغوط عليه ونحن لا
نبرئ ابدا السلطه الشرعيه عن هذا التساهل
وهذا الانبطاح الكبير للتحالف السعودي
الاماراتي واطماعه في سقطره لكن اؤكد لك
يا اختي الكريمه في الاخير ان سقطره لا
يستطيع رئيس ولا رئيس حكومه ولا غيره ان
يفرط فيها هذه دمنا ولحمنا ودرت ولن نفرط
فيها شكرا جزيلا لك عادل الحسني القيادي
في المقاومه الجنوبيه اليمنيه وشكرا لاسعد
بشاره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا من
بيروت وبهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه
الحصاد شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء